大体は座りましたね お静かにお願いいたします
今日は話の4番目でございます
えーと あの タイトルとしては運命と宿命の違いということは書いてございますけど
この話が始まる時 私は一応そこら辺の説明はいたしました
あの 運命って何ですか
宿命って何ですかと 特に仏教ではこの運命ということは認めていないと
それも説明いたしました
で 今日もテーマになっているんだから
タイトルになっているんだから
もうちょっと触れてみます
で 私が知っている限りは
なんか宿命 運命というと
まあそれ正しかどうか分かりませんだけど
なんか変わらないような感じがするんですね
日本語でどう感じるか分かりませんだけど
で 一応宿命といえばなんとなくもう決まってるもので
運命でいえばもう決まってるものだと
だから人のそんな運命は変わらないだろうと思うかもしれません
でも仏教では変わらないものは何一つもないという立場なんですね
変わらないものは一つもありえないんだと
そういうことで 私たちも
例えば あ これは私の運命だ
しょうがないなという風に
もう一般的には決めてしまいますが
しょうがないんじゃなくて
変えようとするならば変えられます
そのことをずっと説明してきました
そういうことで この  仏教のことを信じるか信じないか
それは別なことで 仏教から言うならば
あの まあ自分がどんな不幸な運命に遭う人であろうとも
別に気にしないで それなりに努力すれば
もう何とかいい方向に持っていくことはできるんです
我々の人生っていうのは
ですから 仏教で結局言っているのは
諦めるな 諦める必要はないんだと
とにかく幸福になりたければ
いい方向へ行きたければ
諦めずにそれなりに努力すればよろしいのです
そこで諦めるなと言っちゃったら
じゃあしがみすぎて 自分考えたことに徹底的にもう
もうなんか釘を打ったような感じで
私はこれこそやるぞというふうな感じでよろしいかという問題も出てくるんですね
たまに世の中の人々いるんですよ
なんかやろうと決める
決めて徹底的にそればっかしやろうとする
結局それは失敗で終わって
もう人生も年取っちゃって
他のことできなくなっちゃうんですね
そういう人間も我々に見られるんですね
わからないんだったら
ちょっと私は強引に例を作ってみますけど
例えば音楽家になって有名になりますと
小さい時決めちゃうし
それでいろんな方法でいろいろ音楽を勉強したり
いろんなことを作曲勉強したりして
まあいろいろ仕事しようしようと思ったんだけど
なかなか売れないとか
なかなかいい作品自分に出てこないとか
それで結局他の仕事もできないし
人生は不幸で終わるんじゃないかなと
というケースはね 事実として世の中にあるんですね
どんな人間も自分目指して頑張ったことは成功したというわけじゃないんです
ですから 私が仏教から諦めずに頑張ろうと言っていいのかという問題が出てくるんですね
で そこでもうちょっと仏教で違うことを言うんですね
仏教というのは なんだかんだでも
この原因結果よっていろんな条件が揃ったところで結果が出るんですね
ですから そこら辺も考えなくちゃいけない
諦めず 諦めずに頑張るということは
きちんと客観的に物事を見て判断して
よく合理的に考えながら頑張ることなんです
決して大雑把で考えることではないんです
例えば やればできるという日本語の言葉がございますね
やればできますよと 我々よく子供たちに言うんですね
でも やればできますよということは
すごい大胆な言葉で 真実ではないんです
ちょっと考えちゃうと
もし子供たちに まあ子供たちはすごい性格はいいんだからいいんだけど
もし親がやればできるんだから頑張ってくださいと言ったら
じゃあやれば私は空を飛びますかと
もし子供たちが反論しちゃったら
もうどうしようもないんです
その場合は ですから やればできるという一般的に我々使っている言葉のように
考え方はちょっと仏教から見れば良くないんですね
やっぱりやればできるものもやってもできないものもあるんです
そのやってもできないものっていうのは
非科学的な非合理的なもの
それを覚えておいてください
もう一つ 我々頭の中で一人勝手に妄想してイメージ作っちゃうんです
夢を作るでしょ 自分作る夢
何でも実現できるわけじゃないんです
だから 小さい時に経験もない時
私はこうなります ああなりますとか
なんとか夢作っちゃう
その夢を目指して一生懸命頑張る
頑張ってもその夢は叶わない可能性があるんです
その差を考えてほしいんです
ただ単にいきなり私が日本の総理大臣になりますよとかね
いい加減に決めてはいけないんですね
もしいろいろそういうふうな条件を考えてみたら
なんかやればできないわけないかなとわかったら頑張ってもいいんです
たとえ日本国民みんなに総理大臣になる権利はあります
法律としては だからといって
私も選挙権を持ってるんだから
総理大臣になりたいと思っても総理大臣にはなれないんですね
それにいろいろ原因 条件は必要なんです
ですから そういうものはそこそこ揃ってるんだったら
あるいは自分に揃うことできるなと思ったならば
まあチャレンジするしか方法ないんですね
ですから 運命宿命は変えられます
変えられますけど そこにすごい具体的な
合理的な ちゃんとした科学的な思考を使わなくちゃいけないんですね
で 一般的に宗教で見られる
なんかもうわけもわからなく
お祈りばっかりするとかね
で 神社に行ってなんとか何とかちょうだいちょうだいとかね
で そういうふうなことはあまり仏教ではね
あまり賛成してないんです
でも否定してもないんです
ある面で言えば なぜかというと
例えば神社やら教会やらお寺やらどう書いて
人が何か願い事をするんだと
それはわずかな原因になるんです
自分の運命変えるために
それは仏教での このある一つの心理的なシステムございますね
心の中で それ 一つの条件揃っちゃうんです
やる気ですか いわゆるやる気が出てくる
それからなんとなくまあうまくいくんじゃないかなという
なんとなく心の中であの安心感のようなものが出てくる
だから安心感があると
心の中で人間には行動できます
ですから 心の中 例えばお祈りすることによって
でお祈り対象はどっちでもいいんです
神社でもいいし 教会でもいいし
お寺でもいいし そこら辺にあるどんな木でも石でも何でもいいんです
自分が 信仰して真剣真面目にやれば
いくらかこの自分の心に安心感
自信というものは増えちゃう
つけちゃう で まあおそらくまあうまくいくだろうという風なことが入っちゃうんですね
で それでまあ努力すればうまくいく可能性はあるんです
でも決してあれお祈りしたんだからではないんです
それはわずかな支えになっただけなんです
あくまでも結果はその人の努力次第なんです
そういうことで この あの
運命は変えられますけど
もうそれ中にもいろいろ条件が入っているということを覚えていただければ結構でございます
ですから そこでまあ我々はこの因縁の話ですか
よく仏教で出てくるもので
物事っていうのは まあ因縁によって成り立つんだと
原因がなければ何も現れませんと
いわゆる偶然という言葉は仏教では全くございません
英語でそれ accidental と言うんですね
あれは偶然ですよということはありえないんです
物事はそれなりの何か条件揃ったら起こるものなんですね
で ただ 私たちはたまたま偶然という言葉を使うんです
よくよく見ると 一般的に我々が偶然という言葉を使うのは
予想しなかったという意味なんです
ただ気づいてないだけ
予想しなかったことが起きたら偶然と
何か偶然見つかりましたと
いわゆる見つかるという予想はなかったんです
そこら辺に行けば そういうものは
例えばしいたけを偶然に見つかりましたと
ということは まあそこら辺
ちょっと山を散歩しただけで
しいたけなんか見つかりっこはないと頭でざっくり考えたこともなかったんです
自分がただ散歩したかっただけ
それでそこにしいたけがあって
それは拾うところで これ偶然見つかりましたよと言うんですね
でもそれは偶然ではないんですね
結局は ですから 一般的な社会で
我々は普通に私たちは偶然というのは予想しなかったということだけ
そちらに原因結果というものがなかったということはありえないことで
例えば しいたけよりは松茸にしましょう
その方が理解しやすいんだから
で 山歩きしたと そこでもう 1本の松茸に自分が出会ったと
出会ったらさっさとそれもうやっぱり人のものでも拾うだろうと思いますけどね
で 偶然見つかりましたと言うんですけど
そこで何が原因結果かというと
私たちは松茸に対するいろいろ感情
知識を持ってるんですね
美味しいものだ 高価なものだとかね
なかなか手に入りにくいものだとかこうだとかね
大変 まあ誰でも食べたがる食べ物であって
そこでそういう環境あるところで
自然にそういうものはできたりもする
それ自分の目で見たら
すぐその場で判断しちゃうんですね
で それは取るんです もし松茸っていうのは何者かとさっぱりわからない男の人がそこら辺
子供がそこら辺が歩いたと
その子はそれ見つかるんですかね
見つからないんです 足で蹴っ飛ばすかもしれません
なんだこれと 例えば幼稚園の子供がそこら辺歩いていた
遊んでいたんだと なんだこれこれこれと言って足で踏んじゃうかもしれません
その子には偶然に見つかったってことはないんですね
そこで偶然で言ったっても
それなりに原因結果揃ったら揃ったら起こる出来事で
子供の幼稚園の子供の場合は原因揃ってないんですね
いわゆる松茸に対する知識という条件
その子の心に揃ってない
だから足で踏みつける可能性はある
ということで 仏教においては偶然という言葉はございません
そこで知識人も科学的な世界でも偶然ということを言うんです
科学の世界でも偶然そういうことができたと
起きたと その場合も予想しなかったということなんです
ただ予想しなかったっていうこと
予想しなかったのは それはあなたが悪いっていうことを私簡単に言うんですね
すべての原因結果 いろんなことを初めから考えておくのは
もうあなたの仕事で あなたは考えなかったところで何か起きたと
偶然事故が起きたと 原子力発電所で
偶然できるわけじゃないんです
あなた方が考えなかったと
それは悪いのはあなた方ですよとしか言いようがないんです
ですから 偶然事故を起こすとかありえないんです
よく言うんです それは偶然です
絶対安全でしたとかね
でも後で調べてみると
いろいろ欠陥見つかりましたとかね
あるんじゃないんですかね
それだったら事故は起こします
ですから この存在の中で何一つの偶然というものはないんです
全部いろんな様々な条件が揃ったところで出来上がるものなんです
ですから もうカルマというものも
我々の運命というものも
偶然なものではなくて
いろんな原因結果によって出てくるものです
一応今日のテーマとしては
そこら辺に話を終わりたいんです
で 終わって ちょっと違うテーマに行きたいんだけど
で 運命を変えられる方法は説明いたしましたね
1回目と 2回目はすごい
一応いくらか明確に難しいということも言いましたしね
で 今日言いたいのは この
まあカルマっていうのは結局行為であって
アクションですね カルマっていうのは
まあわかりやすく言えば行為なんですね
働きなんですね 行為といえば
仏教では 3つに分けられるんです
人間の場合は心の行為
言葉の行為 体の行為と
で よくわかりやすく皆様に言うのは
身口意と まあまあ身というのは体
口というのは口 意というのは意識の意
で 身口意の行為 ある心の行為
言葉の行為 体の行為 行為といえば
一般社会では体でやることは大変重く大事に考える
言葉で言うのはそれほど別に気にしない
まあ気にするんだけど
そんなに体でやることほど気にしない
頭で考えることは別に全く気にしない
でも仏教では逆のことを言ってるんです
一番気にしてほしいのは
我々の考え方 次に言葉
次に体の行動 なんでそういうことを言うかというと
このあの行為によって結果が得られるんですね
ですから この意識の方が気をつけてほしいと
で 例えば人が人を殴ったとする
みんなそれ大変なことだと思っちゃう
もう一人があなたぶん殴るそうと言う
あんた何言ってるんですか？と言うだけで
そんなに大変に考えないんです
もう一人の人は頭の中でさんざんこの人をぶん殴って殺した方がいいんではないかと思っている
誰も知らない その本人もすごい
別に何も言ってないんだから大丈夫だとセーフだと思ってるんです
でも仏教から言えばセーフわけじゃないんです
なぜかというと 考えないで喋れないんですね
あの ぶん殴りたいという場合は
と あの ちょっと聞いたら
ちょっと何て言いますか
どうなるんですかね 怖くなるかもしれません
なぜかというと 我々一般的には別に体で悪いことをしているわけじゃないし
言葉を喋る時でも できるだけ丁寧に相手の心を傷つかない
傷つかないように丁寧には喋っているんです
それで私は別に何も悪いことをしていないと自分で思ったりもしていますが
自分は何考えてるかっていうことはあまり気にしない
お釈迦様は徹底的に言うんですけど
あなたは何考えてるかっていうことは一番大事ですよと
一番大事な働きですよと
ですから人は自分を自分のことを気をつけるならば
何を気をつけるんですかというと
あの心を気をつけなくちゃいけない
考え方は気をつけなくちゃいけない
ですから 頭の中で冗談でもふざけてでも悪いことを考えていけないんです
ふざけてでも悪いことを考えちゃうと
それは悪いカルマになっちゃうんです
で そういうふうに考えている途中で喋ったりもする
やがてやったりもする
ですから このまあもう今日も新聞であっただろうと思いますけどね
小学生1年生の子供がもう一人の自分を子供刺して殺してしまったと
で それ殺したということだけ我々は新聞にニュースにしちゃいますけど
それはしょうがないことなんですが
そのその二人がやっぱりずっと心の中で互いに憎しみを持っていたんですね
だからその時からの良くないことをやっていたんです
相手に対して憎しみを持っていました
ずっとそれを頭の中で
もう何て言いますか 発酵して
発酵して やっと言葉に出るようになりました
それからまたもうかなりいろんな時ケンカしただろうと思いますよ
そこで言葉に出る 出て
それでたまらなくて もう手足も出るようになったんですね
手足出るようになったのは
すごい頭の中で ものすごい強烈なエネルギーで憎しみ
怒り 怒りがあったんだからなんです
だからナイフを持って人を刺したこと自体がそんな大きな出来事じゃないんです
人を殺すまで頭の中ですごいエネルギーを持っていたんですね
あれはカルマになっちゃうんです
悪いカルマになっちゃうんです
ですから この我々 このいい社会を作ろうと思うならば
考え方だけ直しておけばいいんです
いろんな規則作っても意味がないんです
ナイフ持つなとかね 武器を持ってはいけませんとかね
規則はあってもあまり意味がないんです
ナイフ持ちたい気持ちを消してあげないと
悪いことは悪い言葉喋るなとか言うよりは
悪いことを喋りたくなる気持ちを消してあげなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから お釈迦様の言葉
立場から申し上げると
社会いい方向へ 我々生きている社会をね
もっと立派な平和な幸福な社会に作り上げたい
変化させたいと思うならば
何かどこら辺 どんな建物を建てればいいかとかね
新幹線またもっと延長すればいいかとかね
そういうことばっかり考えたっても
私はあまり意味がないと思いますね
学校の あの 何て言いますか
建築システム 最近テレビでそういう話もあったんですね
学校の建物の時代悪いんだと
で そんなことでいいかなと
私も笑いながら聞いていたんだけどね
徹夜してずっとやってた討論の討論でしたけど
ある人々はもう学校 今の学校では
この建物はまあ全部監視できるように
コントロールできるようにできているんだと
なんか刑務所のようなものになっているんだから
子供たちに何とか何とか
ああだこうだとかね 自分のいる場所がないんだと
いろんなことを言ってますけど
やっぱりそういうことよりは
この我々の社会 みんなの考え方変えなくちゃいけないんですね
新しい方向へ 美しい考え方が出るような
例えば大人がもう人を管理したい
コントロールしたいという気持ちは私もよく感じるんです
日本にいると なんかみんな相手を抑えたくなってるんじゃないかと
コントロールしたがってるんではないかと
それは消えてないんですね
戦争は終わったんだけど
あの帝国主義はなかなか心から消えてないんじゃないかなと
もしかすると私は間違ってるかもしれませんだけど
それはまあまあ 別にもう外人の意見だから
別にあまり気になさらなくてもいいんだけど
なんか私から見れば なんかまだまだ帝国主義みたいな気持ちないんじゃないかなと感じるとこあるんで
どこへ行ってもなんとなく部下を抑えてコントロールして管理して
もうもう徹底管理なんですね
社会っていうのは発展するといろんな管理システムが自然に出ますよ
それはもうもう避けられない事実なんですけど
で 例えばゴミはこういう風に出しなさいと
ああだこうだとかね まあそれでも聞いてくれない怠け者がいると
まあ透明の半透明のゴミ袋使いなさいとかね
言わなくちゃいけないんだけど
まあある意味でそれも一つの管理なんですね
人のゴミは何ですか？と
まあチェックすることだからね
私もあんまりいい気持ちじゃないんだけど
あんなことではやっぱりいい
気持ちじゃないんだけど
しょうがないんですね
なぜしょうがないかというと
このゴミ出す人々は育ててないんですね
心が黒いビニール袋で全部もう生ゴミも燃えないゴミも全部まとめてポイと捨てちゃいますからね
そこら辺に何が見えるかというと
その人の考え方 社会的じゃない
相手を愛する考え方じゃない
自分だけ良ければ これめんどくさい
だからこの分離するのめんどくさい
もうもう忙しい やらないといって全部出したくなる
だからそこら辺考え方まずいんだから
東京都が半透明のゴミ袋使いなさいと言わなくちゃいけなかったんですね
それで我々も安いゴミ袋使っていたのに
もうちょっと高いゴミ袋使うようになってしまったんです
だからみんなに迷惑なんですね
でも我々みんな やっぱり私たち生きてる環境ではないか
これ守りましょうと 東京都は全然ゴミ分別しませんだけど
我々自分でやりましょうというふうに気持ちになっちゃうと
別に向こう側から私たちを管理する必要なくなっちゃうんです
それで問題なく流れがスムーズにいっちゃうんですね
そういうことで この私たちがやっぱり一番やらなくちゃいけないことは
心の流れを正しい方向へ流すよう流れるように育てることなんですね
ですから 小さい時からも
子供たちにこのいいことを考えるように教えてあげれば
子供たちは悪いことを考えられなくなるんですね
悪いことを考えるのはかっこ悪いんだと
いいことを考えるのはすごいかっこいいと
ふうな感じでなってくると
人間っていうのは悪いことを考えられない
考えられないようになるんです
仏教ではもっとものすごい危ない怖いことを言うんですね
我々 考える瞬間 瞬間 カルマをしているんだと
瞬間 瞬間 でもずっといろんな危ないことを考えてるでしょ
人間頭の中で どんな顔もなんかすごいおとなしい顔したっても
なんかすごい面白いものなんかね
美味しいものお店にあったらあれやればいいなと思ったりするんじゃないか
そうすると財布はなかなかそんなことに応じてくれないと
もう誰かに怒ったりするんじゃないですかね
あるいは自分にも怒ったりするんじゃないんですかね
なんで私にあれ買えるぐらいお金ないんですかとかね
そういう暗い考え方でしょうね
そこの中に怒りがあるんです
それでもう自分知らないうちに悪いカルマをしているんです
そんなことを徹底的に言っちゃうと
人間っていうのはなんかもう
もういても立ってもいられない状態になるんですけど
ですからしょうがないんです
それは事実なんです わずかでも悪いことを考えちゃうと
不幸なカルマしたことになるんです
ですから たとえもう冗談ででもふざけてでも人を憎んだりすること
嫉妬心の中ででも嫉妬したりすること
怒りのことを考え 怒りを持つことなんかはもう確実に悪いカルマになるんです
口で嫉妬の言葉言ってないんだからということでもう逃げることはできないんです
頭で言ってるんだから
泥棒しなくても あれ私私にあればいいなと思うことは人のものね
もう頭で盗みをしているんですね
それも私たちの不幸なカルマになる
ですから 頭の中で美しいもの
生命 愛するものを考えていると
もういいカルマになるんです
どうすれば自分にもっと自分の家族を幸せにしてあげることできるかどうかね
どうすれば自分の子供たちをもっと明るく
楽しく スクスク育てる
育てることできるかないかとかね
どうすればみんな仲良くするでしょうかとかね
家族はもっとお互いに愛情があって
明るくどうすれば生きていられるかとかね
そういう風にこんなことを考えればいいんじゃないんですかね
で そういう方向やいろんなことを考えたりすると
人生はみるみるうちに幸福の方に変わってしまうんです
たとえ悪いが悪い人がいたとしても
あの人本当に悪いですよと思うのは怒りであって
そうじゃなくて なんでその人はそんな悪い人になったんでしょうかと
その人の立場になって考えて
それを理解する なるほど
そういうわけで その人は悪い人間になってしまったね
かわいそうな人やと考えちゃうと
自分の心にあるのは悪い人に対する怒りではなくて
その人はかわいそうだと
という あの 何と言いますか
憐れみの心なんですね
それは素晴らしいいいカルマなんですね
で そういうふうなことで
我々 私達の考え方だけ何とかして直していただけるならば
全てうまくいくのです
法律なくても いろんな規則なくても
全てがうまくいくはずなんです
そういうことで人間には自分の運命変えられるんです
そこでまあ行為の話になったんだけどね
で 人が口で喋ることも全部カルマになる
体ですることもカルマになる
ですから 会社に行っても自分が何かカルマをしているんです
寝ても何かカルマをしているんです
カルマから逃げられないんです
いつでも何か自分の運命に足すか引くか
どっちかの何かをやってるんです
考える時でもそうなんです
そこは覚えておいてください
我々が寝る時も 自分の運命というならば
運命にプラスになる一つ足すか
マイナスになる人を引いてみるか
何とかしているんです
知らないうちに ちょっと工夫次第に全部プラスになるようにすることはできるんです
あまり工夫しないと ご飯食べることによっても悪いカルマしたことになる可能性あります
ちょっと工夫すると ご飯食べることがいいカルマになるんです
あまり気づかないと 会社に行くことは悪い行為になる可能性あります
ちょっと心の工夫しちゃうと
会社に行くことはいいカルマになっちゃうんです
そのちょっとした工夫が分かれば
もう普通の人生をそのままいい方向へ変えてしまっちゃうんです
そのちょっとした工夫って何ですかね
やっぱりいつでも私も言ってる
この貪瞋痴という衝動をやめましょうということ
むさぼり 怒り 無知 それやめて
それの反対の あの衝動を心の中にあるならば
いいカルマになっちゃうんです
ご飯むさぼって食べるんじゃなくて
あの まあこういう美味しいご飯を食べて健康的になって
みんなのために頑張ろうと
という気持ちで食べればいいんじゃないですかね
体が健康でなければみんなに迷惑ですよと
ですから 健康な体をやっぱり何とかして維持しなくちゃいけないんだと
家族のみんなに迷惑でもあるし
私の仕事をできなくなったらみんな大変苦労するんだと
そういうわけで やっぱり選んで美味しいものを食べますと
という風になると その人の考え方はもう別に悪いわけじゃないんです
あいつは美味しいんだから美味しいものを食べるぞとか
金持ちだから高いものばっかりなんで食べるぞと言っちゃったら
もう悪いカルマしてるんです
それは地獄に行く道で
そうじゃなくて やっぱり私が言ったような
ちょっと考え方変えちゃえば
会社にしっかり毎日行って
早く行って遅くまで仕事して
みんなを追い越して自分だけ偉くなってやるぞと思っちゃえば
もうその人は毎日悪を行っているんです
そういう人はもう見てください
結果として決して偉くならないんですね
そういう人々はいろんな汚職したり
いろんな悪いことしたり見つかるでしょうに
そうじゃなくて まあやっぱりせっかくこの会社のおかげで自分たち生きているんだから
日本の社会ももう経済活動
会社なんかうまくいってるんだから
国が安定ですよ みんな安定ですよ
私の家族も安定ですよ
それは壊すことはいけません
しっかりやらなくちゃいけないんだと
責任重大だという感じで
人を抑えて自分を偉くなろうという自己主義じゃなくて
私にとっては責任重大です
しっかり仕事しなくちゃいけないんだと
そういう気持ちでやると
それは私はいいカルマだと思います
そういう人々はもう確実に幸福になると思います
誰にもその人になんか落とし穴を掘ることなんかは不可能なんです
その人は社会に対して
自分の家族に対して 人類に対して
国に対して大変貢献的な何かやってるんです
だから別に大々的なことをやってるわけじゃなくて
ただ会社に行って仕事してるだけなんです
具体的に言えば それでも考え方次第に
それは美しいものにもなる
醜いものにもなる ですから仏教というのは
この大胆な社会革命しようということじゃないんです
社会はその流れに流れるまんまで
別に大したことはないし
そのまま流れたってもいいんですけど
なぜ問題起きたりするかというと
我々の思考が汚れている
ですから 思考法は思考方向性を清らかな方向へちょっと入れておきましょう
で このよく聞こえる話なんですと
学校の先生たちは大変精神的に疲れている
みんなすっごいなんかもう怖くて
学校に 嫌で仕事してるんですね
まあしかすると一番嫌で仕事をしているのはこの学校の先生たちかもしれません
子供たち悪く言ったって叱ってはいけませんし
褒めなくちゃいけないし
悪いことすると褒めちゃうと
もう何やるかわからないし
それで子供たち悪いことしちゃったら
また先生に叱るし 先生が悪い
だからやりきれない状態なんですね
まあそれでその人々も嫌で
まあどうしようもない
この仕事を選んだんだからやらなくちゃいけないと
だからもういい加減でやってるし
そういう風になると やっぱりかわいそうに
その人は毎日悪いことをしているんですね
悪いカルマをしているんですね
それだからその方々は精神的に大変疲れる
ストレス溜まる イカれてしまっちゃうし
だからそれはやっぱり本人の考え方だけちょっと変えれば
だけちょっと変えれば
何のことなく楽に仕事をできるはずなんですね
そういうことで 私たちにはこの毎日我々やっている仕事を
まあ誰でも仕事をしているんだから
おばあさんであろうと
おじいさんであろうが
普通のサラリーマンであろうが
仕事しない人間はいませんし
仕事っていうのは自分の一日のやらなくちゃいけないことは仕事ということだって僕は言ってますからね
会社でやることだけ仕事ではなくて
何でも仕事です で それはやっぱり明るい心でやると
確実に明るい方向へ行って
明るい人生は出ていきます
心汚れでやっちゃうと
かわいそうに自分が自分も不幸になるし
自分の周りの人々も不幸にしてしまっちゃうし
そういう汚れた心で仕事をする人々のおかげで
今日本の経済状態もずっともうどうしようもない状態で困って悩んでいるし
だからこの何人かいればいいんですよ
国自体壊すために それぐらいカルマの働きというのは大変危ないんです
で そういうやっぱり皆様
まあ日本のことばっかり考えちゃうとわからないかもしれませんけど
他の国々のこともちょっと目を通してみてください
このリーダーシップを取っている人々の悪さによって
国自体破壊して倒産してめちゃくちゃになる時
ケースあるでしょうに
言いたい言いたい例はいっぱいあるんだけど
なんかこの場で言ってはいけないなと思いますからね
ちょっと控えますけど
日本のことではなくて
外国のことをいろいろ頭には浮かぶんだけどね
あの国はあの人のこういうことでこうなってるんだと
この国はこういう人でこうなってるんだと
見ればわかるんですね
やっぱり ですから この何人かいればいいんです
国ごとに丸ごとに破壊するために
で 日本でもその痛い味を味わってはいるんですね
ですから これは冗談の話じゃないんです
人間が自分の仕事は清らかな心でやらなきゃどうなるかわからないんです
ですから 真剣に考えなくちゃいけない事実
遠い昔からお釈迦様はおっしゃってるんです
みんなの平和のために
みんなの幸福のために
生きとし生けるものの幸福のために
汚れて考え 汚れた考え方はやめなさいと
心を清らかにしなさいと
徹底的に言ってるんです
そういうのは  誰にでも否定できない
すごい真理であって事実なんです
それは仏教というある宗教の考え方といって否定できないと私は思っているんです
人 誰でも考えて行動する
それは否定できません
じゃあ そこでカルマを
あの 例えば個人の場合はね
個人が悪いことをしちゃったらどうしますか？と
世の中の一般的な考えで悪いことをした人をもう処分しましょうと
というのは世の中の一般的な考え方なんですね
処分して まあ捨ててしまおう
昔のいろいろ宗教的書を読むと
石 石で殴って まあ殺してもいいと
悪いことをしたんだからと
それぐらい一般的な人間考えちゃうんですね
じゃあ悪いことをした人はどうすればいいんですかね
カルマっていうのはいつでも変えられるものなんです
人を否定してはいけないんです
いくら悪いことをしても
悪人も否定してはいけないんです
悪人が悪人になったのは
汚れた思考があったんだからなんです
汚れた思考っていうのは
自由 もう何の原因もなく生まれるわけじゃないんです
我々は育てられた環境によって考えているでしょうに
私たちの考え方っていうのは
学校やら子供たちやら家族やら
自分付き合って生活している社会ありますね
どんな人でも小さな社会ありますからね
そういう社会やらそういう影響で我々の考え方は変わるでしょうね
例えば子供たちが漫画見て
テレビを見て それによって考え方が変わるでしょうね
だから考え方はちょっとしたことで変わっちゃうんです
ということは 悪人がいるとすると
その人は悪い考え方を持っている
そうすると社会にも責任がある
ですから これはちょっと大げさな言い方なんですけど
社会が悪人を作って その社会がその人を処分するということは何のことかと
もっと分かりやすく 私は人にあなたは人を殺しなさいと言って
その人は人を殺しちゃって
あんた人殺しでしょう
あなたはもう処分しますと
ということは不可能でしょうね
ですから 仏教ではこの悪人を否定することはしないのです
悪を行った人は必ず不幸になります
それはしょうがない 誰の責任でもない
その人の責任だから 私たちにその人を否定することはできない
で まあちょっと今日話難しくなるかもしれませんだけど
どうでみんな考えるかもしれませんね
じゃあ悪人放っておけばいいんですか？とかね
とにかく人を人を殺したら
なんで私たちもその人に対して怒って
罪を犯すんですかね 悪人に対しても怒ったら
それも罪なんですね それよりは悲しくなったって
それはそれで終わっちゃいますからね
本当にかわいそうですよと思った方がいいと思いますけど
私はいろいろこの悪いことをして
この人々はね まあニュースなんかに出ちゃうと
本当にその人のことをすごく悲しく感じちゃうんです
この人はもったいないことをしましたとね
頭の悪さ 頭悪くて なんでバカなことをするんですか
すごく痛く感じるんですね
こんな人のせいでこうなったあなたとかね
もう厳しくもう裁かなくちゃいけないとかね
そういうふうなことはあんまり頭に浮かばないんです
で そういう話で言いたがっているのは
この悪を私たちも完璧じゃないんだから
私たちも悪いことをする
いつでも完璧じゃないし
誰でも思考はきちんと綺麗にしたわけじゃないし
たまに汚れるし 汚れちゃったらもう悪いことしているし
人は悪いことをしたって
お釈迦様が言うのは それはいいことで取り消しなさいと
悪行為をした人は その行為の行為のエネルギーを
いい行為をして無効にしなさい
一般日本語で言うならば償いですかね
それなりに償いをしなさいと
して いっぱい良いことをすればいいんです
いっぱいじゃなくて お釈迦様の立場から言えば
人間はもうずっといいことばっかしなきゃいけないんです
そのままそれは難しいんだから
考え方はきれいにする
思考だけきれいにする
汚れないようにする そうすると我々やることは全部いいことばっかし
もう安心です 安全です
ですから もうもし心が汚れていた時
この話を聞かなかった時ね
過去で何か悪いことしたならば
じゃあその日からずっといいことだけし続ければもう大丈夫ですよ
で あのゲイなんですけど
お釈迦様はこう読むんですね
これヤッセと読むんです
これパーパン  パーパン
書き方はヤッサ パーパン
ハタン カンマン ヤッサっていうのはまあ誰かがっていうことで
誰かが あのカンマンっていうのは業ですね
パーパンカンマンっていうのは悪業ですね
パーパンっていうのは罪
悪 ハタンっていうのはしかならば
もし誰かが悪業を行ったならば
それを それを クサレーナピティーヤティ
クサレーナっていうのは善
善行為 罪の反対 善 善行為をもってピティーヤティっていうのは
まあ隠すって意味なんですけど
消すということなんですね
もし悪いことをしたならば
それを善行為で消してしまう
三行目 そう 彼はイマンローカン
この世の中でって意味なんで
世っていうのは人間の中でって意味でいいんです
この世の中でイマンローカン
この世の中でパバーセーティっていうのは輝く
また文章続くんです それで終わります
アッバーモットーワチャンディマ
アッバーっていうのは雲
雲から出てきた モットーっていうのは出てきた
チャンディマ 月のように
それはあの詩なんです
お釈迦様の説いた一つの詩なんです
ですから四行があって
これ見にくいだったら上に書きましょうか
この四行目を上に書きます
これは一 アッバー 雲からもっと出てくるチャンディマ
月のように ですから 雲から出てくる月のように
その人はこの世の中で輝くと
[背景の雑音]ですから意味は
もし人が悪いことをしたならば
それをクサレーナ ピティーヤティ
善行為でそれを無効にする
隠しておく いわゆる消えるようにする
いっぱい善行為をして
それでその人は輝くんだと
ということは 悪いことをすると暗いんです
隠れなくちゃいけないんです
月が雲に隠れているんです
雨雲に もう見えない 暗い
それで善行為をすると
その雲が出て行って また月が美しく輝き始まるんです
ですから 人間の心がまた再び輝く
輝き始まりますよと ですから
悪いことをしたんだからしょうがないとかね
ということはないんです
それから気づいたといいから
いっぱい良いことをしなさい
そうすると あなたの心はもう何も問題なく輝きますよと
一番上書いたのは この一番下の行
またあの同じ行を書き写しただけ
行ですね この言葉は  そういうわけで
あの 私たちはまあなんか悪いことしたんだからといってね
ずっと人生暗く暗く 死ぬまで暗く生きる必要ないんです
悪いこと まあどうせ考え方はね
完全じゃないんだから
まあそんなことは起こり得るんです
起こったらすぐそこ あ
これ悪いことしてしまったと
しっかりとそれを実感して理解して
それから二度とやらんと
その代わりにいっぱい良いことだけするんだと
行動的になればもう問題なく美しく輝くんだと
幸福になるということ
あの仏教のストーリーとしてあります
このもうもう九百人以上人を殺した人がいて
お釈迦様の時代で その人もお釈迦様に会って法を聞いて悟ったんです
いろんな悪いことをした人も
もうやっぱり最後にお釈迦様に会って心清らかにして
まあ幸福になったケースいろいろあるんです
ここでそういうストーリー言ったでしょうかね
ちょっと覚えて思い出しませんだけど
で 一人の人がね あの まあもし一回申し上げたならば大変申し訳ないんだけど
あの ある人がね まあ仕事を何もできなくて
まあ泥棒したかったんですけど
泥棒のやり方わからないで泥棒のグループに入っちゃったんです
入ったらそのグループの人々は
この人はすっごい悪い人やと
もう信頼できない ですから
この泥棒の中にも入れてあげることできないんだと
泥棒の中に入れてあげることできないほど悪い人なんです
性格みたいな 帰って帰れと言っても
その人は帰らないんで
一生懸命その人々面倒見るんです
料理作ったり 面倒見たり
もう洗濯物したり ああだこうだ
これ毎日毎日丁寧にやってくれると
まあしょうがなくなっちゃうんですね
それでまあいいやと思って
まあ泥棒のグループに入れてもらったんです
入れてまあ初仕事をしようと
まあ言ったところで どうせこの人は下手だからね
そんなにまあ泥棒する
まあ技そんなに習ったわけでもないし
もう捕まったんです みんな
捕まったらこの王様がみんな打ち首だと決めちゃって
で でも王様には死刑執行人がいなかったんです
その時 で これお釈迦様の時起きた出来事なんです
で そこであの あなた方の一人がこの人々の首を切るんだったら
その人に命を助けてあげるんだと言ったんです
言ったらこの泥棒のリーダー
親分 その頭に聞いたらどうですかね
これは それはできませんと
みんな私の親戚でもあるし
兄弟でもあるし 私はその私の仲間を殺すことはできない
2番目に聞いたらそれもできませんと
誰も互いに相手を殺したくないんです
それで最後にいたこの人に聞いたら
まあ本当に私の命を助けてくれるんだったら
私はやってあげますと
ということで で それでその人にまあその泥棒のグループの首を切るようになったんですね
そこで王様の立場から見れば
この人はもう悪人の中での悪人だから
平気で人を殺しちゃいますから
一緒に仲間で泥棒したでしょうと
やっぱりもう死刑執行人として必要なのはそんな人間なんですね
で その人はもうあなたは殺しませんと
でもこれからこの仕事をしなさいと言って
一応閉じ込められたんです
だからずっと刑務所の方に
まあ別に刑務所に入れたわけじゃないんだけど
まあそこら辺にいなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでずっともう 60 年間人殺しちゃったんです
で 最後になってすごい年でも人殺せないんですね
で まあ二 三回もう首を切らなくちゃ切れないんですね
それはよくないと 王様はね
まあその人もう何て言いますか
仕事を辞めさせたんですね
あんたもう年でもうダメですよと
もうダメですよと言ったら
もうやっとその人は自由になったんです
自由になって まあ普通の人間に戻って
で 自分の家に戻って なんかご飯作って
ご飯って言ったってお粥みたいなものなんですけど
それ食べる前にまあちゃんと体洗って綺麗になって
綺麗な服を着て 初めて楽しくご飯を食べようと思ったところで
お釈迦様の弟子のサーリプッタ尊者でしょうかな
で 托鉢に行ったんです
そちらに行ったら その人は急に
私は一度もこういう聖者ですか
見たことがないんだと
今までそんな人に会う機会もなかったと
やっと今日もう自由になって会うことができたと
それで私にお供えできるものもあるんだと
ですから これ私食べるよりは
せっかくこんな機会は二度と出てこないんですから
ということで お布施するんですね
ただサーリプッタ尊者それもらって帰っちゃったんだけど
その人は自分がやったいいことで
すごく喜びを感じて やっといいことができた
よかったよかったと その場で心臓麻痺で死んじゃったんです
死んじゃったところで
みんなあの人はもうとんでもない悪人だから
どんな地獄に落ちただろうとか話なんですね
そしたらお釈迦様 なんのことなく
あいつは今天国にいるんだと
だからみんなびっくり
みんなびっくりするでしょうね
言ったらやっぱりまあ悪いことをしたのは確かですけど
彼が最後にすごいいいことをして
その明るい心で心 明るさで満ち溢れた瞬間で死んだんだと
ですから 悔しいかもしれませんだけど
その人は今天国に生まれたんだと
そういうストーリー 結構あるんです
そういうことで まあ若い時いいことをできなくて
できなくなった できなかったならば
中年の時でもいいことをしなくちゃいけないと
中年の時もできなかったならば
後でもいいことをしなさいとお釈迦様は徹底的に言うんですね
まあそういう偈文全部意義はできますけど
これめんどくさいですね
文章も長いし 書くのめんどくさいし
まあ一行だけ書きましょうか
もういっぱい いや いくらでもありますね
ちょっとこれも偈なんかな
歌詩なんですけど 四行全部書かないで一行だけ書きます
一行だけ ティンナンアンニャタランヤーマンパティジャッゲイヤパンディト
まあカタカナで書くと分かりやすいんだけど
はい これはアンニャタランと読むんです
ティンナンアンニャタランヤーマンティンナンアンニャタランヤーマンパティジャッゲイヤパンディト
今度は読み方は簡単です
私はちょっとカタカナも書くのちょっと間違えちゃいます
書くと で 説明いたします
ヤーマンっていうのは
あの 何といいますか このピリオド意味で
この人間にはつのピリオドありますね
若い時 中年の時 老年の時って
そのつヤーマンっていうのはそういうことで
ティンナンというのはつ
アンニャタランというのはつの中でどちらかということなんです
ですから 我々の人生のつのピリオドの中で
どちらでもいいんだから
パティジャッゲイヤ パティジャッゲはすごい意味深いことで
パティジャッゲというのはこの処理するって意味なんですね
修理するって意味なんです
人生の修理しなさいって意味なんです
いわゆるいいことをして心を清らかにしなさいと
いつでもいいんだから
若い時できなかったら中年の時やりなさいと
中年の時できなかったら老年の時やりなさいと
その三 何て言いますかね
そのつの それ日本語でもちゃんとした言葉あるんです
そのつのステップの中で
どちらでもいいんだから
自分の人生の修理をちゃんとしなさいと
パンディトっていうのは賢者
その人は賢者 知恵ある人だと
頭いい人で だから意味はこう言うと
頭がいい 頭がいい人であるならば
この人生の あの 三 なんか日本語の言葉あるんですが
何ですっけ まあピリオドでいきましょう
知恵のある頭のいい人であるならば
人生のつのピリオドの中で
どっちかでちゃんと心の修理をしなさいと
心の掃除をしなさいと
そういうことで やっぱりまあ仏教でいうのは悪いことをしたんだからといってね
暗くなる必要は仏教では認めないんです
どんな理由があっても
人間が暗くなって否定的になって
避けてはいけないんです
大変もったいないこと
とにかく間違ってもいいんです
それはもう過去に置いといて直せばいいんです
人生の修理をすればいいんです
ということ なんか次の話にだんだん行くような感じがしますから
まあそこら辺で一応 話を止めて他のテーマに行きたいんです
で これから次のポイントに行きます
で 行為はカルマであるというんです
で どんな行為もカルマになるわけじゃないんです
もう違う立場で考えちゃって
今私は最初は全く違うことを言ったんですね
人をやることは全部カルマですよ
喋ることを考えること
やることを全部カルマで言ったんだけど
今全く違うことを言っているんですね
全部カルマになるわけじゃないんだと
それはこういうこと 我々の行為は他の生命に関する行為なんです
喋ると人に喋る あるいは動物にでも喋る
体で何かすると 他の生命に対して体で何かをする
それで善行為か悪行為になっちゃうんです
例えば 私は手を伸ばして人を殴ったら悪行為
ただなんか空気の中でこうやってパンチですか
ボクシングの真似事したっても
それは悪行為になるはずがないんです
誰にも殴ってないんだから
ただ自分で楽しくね パンチやってるような感じでやってるだけなの
それでも頭のイメージで人を殴ってることをイメージしちゃったら悪いカルマなんです
そうじゃなくて ボクシングやってる人々はサッサッサと手を動かすことはすごいかっこよくなっちゃって
自分でも 自分もそれを真似事をなんとかやるならば
別にその人は楽しがっていることだけで
で 頭の頭のイメージの中でも
誰か相手をぶん殴ってるようなイメージでパンチやっちゃうと
空で空のパンチやってるかもしれませんだけど
これはもう悪行為になるんです
それでポイントはわかるでしょうかね
やっぱり生命に対する行動でないと
まあカルマとは言いにくい
で その生命っていうのは人間だけじゃないんです
生物も生命なんです 私たちが知ってる世界でも
仏教の人は色々神々の世界あるし
梵天という高次元的な世界があるし
地獄というものすごい幅広い色々次元の地獄がたくさんあるし
だからどんな生命に対してでも
他の生命の行動は行為になるんです
例えば天国を想像します
行ったことがないんですかね
なければ想像するしか方法ないんです
で 天国に神々がいるんだと
それで神々がその仲間
自分と同じ天国の住民たちに対して喋ったり行動したりすることは
そこでカルマになるんです
天にいるんだからといって行為はないわけじゃないんです
地獄はどうですか？行ったことがありますかね
じゃあなければ想像する
ないんだけど 例えば地獄に生命がいるんだと
それは地獄にいる生命が互いにいろんなことをやったりすると
それはまた行為になっちゃうんです
カルマになっちゃうんです
どこにいたっても まあ残念ですけど
業からはもう逃げられない
それで生命が相手でなければただの行為
で 私はナイフを持って
どうかな ちょっと例えばゴミ何かとかね
あって それを切ったりすると
それで悪いカルマしてるわけじゃないでしょうに
例えば落ちた枝がある
私はナイフ持っている
ナイフを持ってその枝をナイフで切る
枝自体別に生命ではないし
あるいは枝にナイフでいろいろ刺したり刺したりする
あるいは何かボードを持ってきて
ナイフでそのボードに狙って打つとかね
ちゃんとターゲットに打てるかないかとかね
それは悪い行為じゃないんです
別に なぜならば 相手が単なるボードだから
でも もし私がそのナイフを持って動物を刺しちゃったら
そこで悪い行為 相手がいるんだから
そこで動物を刺したら悪い行為
それ人になっちゃったらもっと悪い行為になっちゃうんです
刺す人によって刺される人によって
カルマのエネルギーが強くなったりする
ですから 行為っていうのは
我々はいつでも他人 他の生命に対してやることなんです
そこで問題は考えることも同じなんですね
我々はやっぱり他の生命についていろんなことを考えたりしているんです
憎しみも誰かについて憎しんでるんです
怒りも誰かに対して憎しんでるんです
ですから ですから 考えることもカルマになってしまっちゃうんです
人間はですね 海へ出て漁をしますよね
魚を捕りますよね その捕った魚を食べますね
これはこういうことは昔からやってきているわけですけど
これは人間の悪業とは言えないですよね
まあ悪業 私には決断できませんだけど
立場によって悪業にもなるんですけどね
立場によって  人の心の持ち方によって
いつか CW ニコルさんってらっしゃいますけど
山なんかに行った時に釣りをして夕食を食べます
その時に人のその自分の体になるわけですから
感謝して それで捨てないというか
全部綺麗に食べると だから感謝して無駄にしない
普通は暮らしてますと食べ物とか余って捨てちゃいます
それをしない  その魚の持っている命のエネルギーも人間がいただくということですね
まあまあ そういう行動もまた仏教的という仏教の考え方ではないんですけどね
仏教から言えば 人間 なんとかこの悪の意識をなんとか和らげようとしていることなんですけど
仏教はやっぱり考えると厳しいんですね
で まあ一応立場説明いたしますけど
例えば猟師が殺生しているんです
確実に ですから猟師は殺生の罪なんです
その場合も その人の心次第に罪がどれぐらいになるかということは
また私たちはわからない
それはカルマのすごいわかりにくいところなんです
で 猟師もこれ私がやらなきゃやる人はいないんだと
人間も誰でも何か例えば食べなくちゃいけないとか
そういうことを考えて
また殺される側に対してもいろいろ感謝があったり
もう大変哀れみな気持ちあったりやっちゃう
その分カルマの変化があるんですけど
消えることはない その人悪いことをしていないということにはならない
どうせ殺生しているんだから
もし魚のことを本当に愛情を持って考えちゃうと殺せませんでしょ？で
我々 例えば食用の魚を買っているとする
買っていると食べられないでしょうに
その魚が 魚をどうしても愛情を持って育てているんだから
ですから やっぱりもう他の生命はやっぱり奪うっていうことをしちゃうんですね
ですから 罪からは逃げられないんですね
そこで 食べる側の場合は
またいろいろ条件があるんですね
で 食べる側はもう食べるんだから殺してるっていうことも事実ですし
食べなきゃ向こうは商売ないんだからやめるし
でも世の中でそんなことはあり得ないことでね
人間みんな人類や魚食べるの肉食べることやめましょうということがあったら
それで殺生はなくなりますけど
それもあり得ないんですね
ですから 例えば我々個人で考えちゃうと
私個人が店にスーパーに行くと
そこで死んでる魚があるんですね
この死んでる魚っていうのは単なる物体なんですね
そちらに命がないんです
ですから まあそれはまあこの物体エネルギーをいただこうという感じだったら
別に何の罪も犯してるわけじゃないんです
その場合は これは取り立ての魚だ
これは美味しいんだ これはこのなんとか何とかところで横浜湾で取られて
まあ横浜の魚は美味しくないかもしれませんだけど
まあそれは新潟で取れた魚だとかね
これだから美味しいとかいう感じになっちゃうと
なんか命まで食ってることになっちゃうんですね
その場合はちょっと汚れると思います
それからこの高級店だったら魚泳いでるんですね
それ注文して これとこれお願いしますって言っちゃったら
まあその場でさばいて調理してくれる
それで食べる人はちゃんと殺生の罪に
責任持たなくちゃいけないです
でも死んでる魚でもそれを食べたいと思うことは完全的に
いつでもそうならないんですね
それが人の心の気持ち次第といったら
それが複雑なんです だから仏教は科学って科学的に見るんだから
物事を 魚 死んだ魚っていうのはもう命が抜けてるんだから
ただの物体で 人が死んじゃったらどうします？燃やしちゃうでしょうね
何もありがたいも何も思わないで
自分の母親であろうか
死んじゃったら平気で燃やすでしょうね
魚死んでも犬豚が死んでも死体は死体なんですね
それはただの物体 で料理しちゃったら
例えば野菜には命があるんだけど
料理しちゃったらもう物体なんですね
そちらにはもう何も問題ないんです
だからはい  そうしますと
あのお肉屋さんで お肉屋さんは牛とか飼ってるとこありますよね
それ食用にして それを飼ってて殺す人がいますよね
で 頭をなんか抱いて 常にその人たちを殺してるわけですよね
私たちはスーパーでパックにしたのを買って食べてます
その殺す人っていうのは罪
になるんですね  その人はそれを仕事にして
ずっと毎日毎日やってるわけですよね
それは私テレビで見たんですけど
常にその仕事で殺してるわけです
ですから悲しいんだけど
やっぱり罪にはなるんです
でも例えば その人はこれ私は言ってはいけないことなんですけど
その人は十頭の牛を殺しちゃったと
私たちがすっごい腹が立って
一頭の牛を殺した場合は
もしかすると私たちの罪が重いかもしれません
私はすごい怒りでもう腹が立って
あの人に損害をしなくちゃいけないとかなんとかわけで
牛一頭殺しちゃったとすると
私たちは本当にもう殺生ということをやっちゃうし
あの人の気持ちとしては殺生は殺生なんですけど
なんかまたいろいろ考え方でもう分かりにくいんですね
心の状態っていうのは
ですから お釈迦様が言うのは
カルマだけは判断してはいけないんだと
それは人間に分かりませんと
考えない方がいいと 僕は最初の講義で言ったんです
それはすっごい考えにくい世界なんですね
例えば僕らから見れば
本当におっしゃる通りに私も同じ
すっごいなんかこのなんか変な気持ちになるんで
そういうものを見ると
で たまに自分も食べたりするし
結局もうまた買いやすいし
例えばどんな店に行ったっても
弁当買おうと思ったっても
肉魚入ってない弁当はほとんどないし
それであるといえば海苔巻きしかない
毎日そればっかり食べるとまた気持ち悪いし
ですから 他のどんな弁当にしたっても一部入ってるし
だから自分も食べてるでしょという気持ちもそこにあるし
植物は生き物  植物にしたっても
やっぱり命があるんですね
でも動物ほど強烈じゃないんです
精神的なエネルギーは少ないんです
でも心が それはちょっと仏教で答えてないし
そうなんですね まあ私から言えば命だと私も個人的には思ってるんですね
お釈迦様もその矛盾があるんだから
そこら辺ちょっとあの
どうせ人間生きていなくちゃいけないし
人間に死になさいということはもう何の意味もないことですし
まあなんかそこら辺ちょっと置いておくんですね
でも我々にとってきちんとわかりやすく言ってるんです
出家にとって 出家っていうのは社会から出た人々でしょ
だから我々は仕事してはいけないんです
なぜならば 仕事をするために罪を犯さなくちゃいけないんです
だから 罪を犯したくなければ出家しなさいと
たとえやっぱり欲があって
競争心がなくて 欲がなくて
競争心がなくて 仕事なかなか難しいでしょうし
たとえ店員やったっても
隣の店よりはこちらちょっと値段引いてあげようと思っちゃうと
こちらから物を買うでしょうに
それは相手に対してね
なんとかの競争でしょうし
そういうものがないとやっぱり仕事できない
だから心を完璧に清らかにしたければ
解脱体験したければ もう出家するしかないという風になっちゃうんですね
それで出家した私たちには料理してはいけないんです
料理さえ 料理するためには
生きている野菜なんか使わなくちゃいけないでしょ
豆でも豆煮で食べようと思ったって
豆は生きているんだから
ですから 出家には料理してはいけませんというふうに言ってるんです
そこで僕が分かったのは
なるほど お釈迦様がやっぱり植物に生命あるということは理解していたんだけど
人間困るんだからおっしゃってないんだと
ですから人間に実行できるところで殺生してはいけないんだと
ですから 仏教の人々は殺生する仕事をやめてくださいと
例えばおっしゃった通りに
牛とか殺してる人が仏教徒になりたというならば
まあ仕事と一緒にもう仕事も辞めなくちゃいけないんですね
でもその人にすっぽんしかいないかというと
だから今そうと言ったのはそういうことなんですね
たとえ悪くした人を否定してはいけないし
その人も被害者であるし
我々は食べるんだからね
労使と言わらうん 盗殺と言うんですか
そういう人々はそういうことをやってるんだから被害者でもあるし
ですから我々は憐れみの心を持ってその人々に接しなくちゃいけないし
で やがて仕事を辞める
そろそろこの仕事辞めるだろうと思ったところでもいて
じゃあこれからいいことをしたらどうですかとかね
これから何かいろいろいいことをしたり
瞑想したり見たらどうですかと
そうすると その人は私はずっと牛を殺してきたんだからダメですよと
だからいいんじゃないか
それは過去でしょうと
牛を殺したんだからって
ずっとそのことを考える必要ないでしょう
綺麗さっぱり忘れて瞑想しましょうと言うと
心は清らかになってしまうんですね
もしそればっかり言っちゃうと
罪を犯してもいいんだという
なんか人間とんでもないことを考えちゃうんですね
そういうことで カルマはなんかやっぱり複雑であることはそのまま置いておかなくちゃいけないんです
だから 漁師さんも殺生するんだと
それは罪だと言っておかなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあ漁師さんには救う道がないかというと
いえ あります 人殺し屋にもあったんだから
あります ですから そういうふうなことで
我々はなんとか理解しておかなくちゃいけない
すごい複雑なんです ですから
肉食べる私の気持ち次第に殺生に参加もできるし
参加しないこともできるし
私はもうなんとか神戸のなんとか牛肉しか食べませんよとかなんとか言っちゃうと
ちょっと自分が生きている動物に関係持つようになっちゃうし
じゃあなんとかもう菜食取って食べましょうと思っちゃったら
まあ生きていなくちゃいけないんだから
まあそこらへんあるものを買って食べようと思ったら
その人はその生命のことは
あまり考えないし 例えばまあ例えば干し魚とかありますね
それはもう死んで水分前のものであるし
ですからまあ 今もうさばいたばっかりの魚しか買わないというよりはね
例えば干し魚があった方がいいかもしれませんし
だからそこら辺はあまり余計に考えると
生きていられなくなるんですね
だから生きていられなくなるまで余計なことを考える必要はないんです
問題は私から言うならば
生きていること自体問題ですよと
輪廻にいること自体問題です
だから輪廻を脱出しなさいとお釈迦様が言うんです
解脱しなさいと 本当のことを言うと
これ僕の言葉なんですけど
生きること自体が罪なんです
どういったってももうどうしようもない状態だからね
幸福とか不幸っていう
普通にある不幸になる幸福
幸福 不幸 幸福 不幸 ちょっとよくわからないです
結局幸福になるってこと？解脱するっていう
究極的な幸福  ありえない
そう   究極的なレベルでこういう風に考えるんですけど
究極的にできないという話ですね
はい  それで幸福になるっていうことですか？ありえない
現実に考えると もう別に
私なんかからしたら それは世俗的なレベルでどういうことなのか
要するにお釈迦様っていうか
多分修行者にしか話してないということですね
大抵の場合 修行しようっていう
ある程度そういうものがあったから
そういう気持ちのある人しか喋ってないわけですか
そうでもないんです ものすごい最近の人々にずっと喋ってきました
なんか本を読む  たくさんあるのは出家者に喋ったこと
なぜならば お経覚えて記録したのは出家者なんですね
だから自分に関心があるものは
自分の修行に必要なものは全部覚え
どういうふうに喋ったか分からないよね
あります だから残ってるお経からしばらく喋ってるんだから
あまり関心はなかったんですね
お釈迦様は要するにそういう財形で世俗的に幸福になるという財宅っていうか
世俗的な意味幸福になるという
あのお釈迦様の教えのこういう順番があるんですね
だから人の能力次第に喋る
まずで 人が私の家族がどうやって幸福になりますかと質問したら
家族が幸福になるところまで教えるんです
あるバラモン人が年取ってもう死に死に損になっていたんです
そこで彼がサーリプッタ尊者に会って友達でしたけど
どうですか？と言ったら
まあもう死にかけてるんだと
それでいろいろ話したところで
彼が梵天という言葉を聞いた途端
梵天ですと すごくそこに気に入っちゃったんですね
梵天に行きたいと ああ
それだったら梵天に行く方法を教えますよと
その場でそれを教えて
瞑想をちょっとさせたって
彼が死んで その場で梵天に生まれたんですね
ですから それはもうしょうがないし
その人の場合は それで王様たちやら金持ちの人々やら
この奥さんたちやら いろんな人生の問題を聞いたら
それなりに幸福論を喋るんです
全部相対的な幸福なんですね
いろんな人いるわけですから
世俗的にちょっとあれになりたいとか
ちょっと幸せになりたいってなんとなく思っているけど
その釈迦 お釈迦様が本当に一番言いたかったことは何かっていうことを知りたい
だから一番言いたかったことにはもう自然に流れていくんです
だから今も今問題が出てきたところで
自然に問題が出たんですね
あなたがおっしゃっているように
結局考えると 幸福って何者かと
幸福っていうのはあり得るんですかと
そこまで来てほしいんです
本当は 急にそれを言ったらみんな逃げちゃうんですね
だからお釈迦様 順番にちゃんとした合理的な教えだから
まあ心はこうこうすればこうこうなります
こうこうすればこうなります
どんどん言っていて ちゃんと心の働きが分かってくると
まあこういうことだよと
本当は輪廻は全部大変なきっかけだよと
怖いんですよと 生きること自体怖いんですよと
だから輪廻を脱出することしか推薦できませんというところまで人の智慧を持っていくんです
で 急に解脱の話をすると
誰も理解してくれません
なぜかというと 我々は生きることにすごい執着を持ってるんです
例えば涅槃に入ったらどうなるんですか？ 質問までするんです
永遠ですか？幸福ですか？ああだこうだと
で それぐらい生に執着しているんです
ですから絶対理解してくれないし
仏教の話も聞いてくれない
それでお釈迦様は順番に教えましょうとということで順番に教え始めたんですね
そこでカルマ論もあまりお釈迦様カルマ論も喋れませんし
で まあ時々喋ってはいるところあるんだけど
私も最初からもうなかなか喋りたくないテーマなんですね
やっぱりすっごい複雑になってしまうし
最後に頭がこんがらがってしまっちゃうんです
どうせ ですから一応今そういうテーマが出たんだから
質問出たんだから まあ結局はお釈迦様いうのはどんな幸福になったっても生きてるんだったらそこにもうなかなか問題があるんだと
で そこにもいろいろストーリーあるんで
例えばお釈迦様も王様で生まれて王様で生まれたっていうことは一番幸福なところでしょうに
それ捨てるんでしょう
そんなことをやったらもう罪ばっかりだよと
お釈迦様の弟子もものすごい豊かで生まれたんです
でも全部財産捨てちゃうんですね
このマハーカッシャパという 3番目の弟子が
もう 80億金貨ぐらい財産あって
それで喧嘩 結婚した女性もそれぐらい財産の持ち主でしたし
二人とも一人娘一人息子で結婚した時からもうやっぱりこんなことを維持することは我々は罪を犯すことだと
なんでこんなことをやらなくちゃいけないと二人とも話し合っていて
両親が死んだすぐその次の日
もう全部捨てて家出したんです
そういうのはもう記録しているし
ですから 結局仏教では世俗的な幸福っていうのはもう何の意味がないんですよということは言ってるんです
言ってるんだけど それ納得してほしいんですね
ですから ちょうど思う具合に皆さん
私はちょっと避けよう避けようと思ったところを
私に質問したことで もうちゃんとその問題が出てきて
大変ありがたいと思ってますけど
私はこれちょっと混乱しちゃったら私も困りますから
そこら辺ちょっと避けて避けておこうと
まあ一応そういうことなんですね
まあ次の講演で言いますから
仏教の道はカルマをすることではないんです
カルマを捨てることなんです
カルマから脱出することなんです
いわゆる解脱なんです
そこら辺  5番目で私はまあ適当に
あの ちょっと触れてみようかなと思っていたんです
とにかくカルマ論というのはごちゃ混ぜになりますからね
まあテーマは明確にいかないと
私は初めからおっしゃってあったし
そういうぐらいでよろしいですか
やっぱり感謝したからいいんだとか
感謝したからいいんだとか
なんかそういういろんな
そういうのは人間の欺し
っていうのはだいたい違うし
そうそうそう それはそうなんです
はい まあそういう風に
それは人間の なんとなく自分の罪意識をなんとか紛らわそうとすることで
ですから 罪悪意識を紛らわす
紛らわすんではなくて
ちゃんと問題見た方がいいんです
問題を見ると怖くなるかもしれません
それはしょうがないんです
これから魚食べられないかもしれません
でもどうしようもないんです
それ知った方が知らないよりはいいんです
それにこのナーガセーナという仏教の世界で現れた大変論争のすごいお坊さんがいたんです
そのお坊さんがこう言うんです
あの質問は罪だと知らない人が
これは悪いことだと 全然知らない人が何か悪いことをしたっても
知らないんだからいいんじゃないかと聞いたら
そのお坊さんがこう言うんです
知らない人が悪いことすると罪が多いんだと
これは悪いんだ 知った上でやる人の罪がちょっと少ないんだと
そう言ったらおかしいんだと
この王様が言うんだ あんた言うことおかしいんだと
例えば人殺しはいけないと知ってる人が人殺しと人殺しと
まあ殺したっても自分殺されるんだから殺してもいいんじゃないかと思って人殺すと
それでなんで人殺しはいけない人が人殺したら罪が少ないんですか？と聞くんですね
法律の場合で言えばわかりやすいかもしれません
私はそういう法律はあったことは知らなかったと
全く知らなかったと 大変申し訳ないという人のそれが少ないんではないかと我々も思っちゃうんです
で このナーガセーナ長老が言うのは違いますと
例えばここにあの真っ赤に温めたあの鉄の玉があるんだと
それは人に触る 取ろうとする人に取りなさいと言うと
それで一人の人が全然知らない
これ真っ赤に暖かくなった
もう鉄の玉だと知らない人はサッと取ろうとすると
それでこれは取ったらすごい火傷するするだろうと思ってる人もそれ取ってみると
どちらの方が火傷多いかと聞くと
やっぱり知らない人の方が火傷の方が多いんですね
ですから カルマのことを知らない人がたくさんカルマを作るんです
だから輪廻の中でどうしようもない状態に我々
みんな刑務所の中にいるんです
もうどうしようもないんです
でもその知ってる人がのカルマがいくらか和らがるんです
大変な厳しいシステムなんです
だからお釈迦様が言っているような輪廻ではね
わずかないいとこもないんだと
天国に行ってみる わずかないいところもないんだと
すごい頂点になる梵天なんか行ってみる
何もいいとこないんだと
その三界 色界 欲界 色界
無色界という 仏教では世界三界に分けてるんで
全部あの大きなこの火が燃えてる
この大きな何て言いますか
大きな穴三つに例えてるんです
例えば人が走っていて
人が穴に落とそうとするんだと
その穴の中で猛烈に火が燃えてて
すごい火があるんだ その上
この鉄の槍いっぱい植えてるんだと
そこでそのあなたはここに落とすそうと言ったら
これはもう槍は鉄だから私は好きですよと
この人はそこに落ちたったらどうなるかというと
やっぱり火で燃えて槍で刺されて死んじゃうと
あ これは危ないと行ったところで
じゃあそれだったら次の穴にあなたを落とすんだと
次の穴に行ってみたら
そこにまた猛烈に火が燃えていて
そこには槍は銀でできているんです
鉄ではなくて すごい高価な穴なんです
銀で飾って 真ん中すごい火が燃えていて
もう銀の槍が全部出ているんだと
じゃあそこに落とすんだと
高価でしょうと 行ったそこに落ちちゃっても同じ結果で苦しみですと
で じゃあ次に持ってきますと
次は金で作ってるんです
穴も金で作って もう槍も全部金で作ってるんです
で そこまた燃えているんだと
そこに落ちるんかと どっちかに落ちなくちゃいけないんだと
あなたは それは色界 無色界
欲界 色界 無色界と三界の例えなんです
ですから たとえ修行して梵天に生まれたっても
たとえ天国に行っても
結局意味がないというのは
まあ釈迦様 本当に出家者に徹底的に言う言葉なんですね
ですから 本当に出家者だけに行っている言葉っていうのは
一般人に向いて言うのさえ難しいんです
すごいもう怖いんです
怖いんだけど それを我々怖いと感じるだけで
事実は事実なんです まあ一応そこら辺でそういう話を置いておいて
そちらの方おっしゃってるように
このごまかしはよくないんです
例えば私は感謝して食べてるんだからいいんだと
それよりはもうたとえ感謝であっても
この動物は死んだでしょうと思った方がいいんです
私は食べるんだから この生命は死んでるんだと
そう思った方がいくらかはいいかもしれません
それで生きることはちょっと苦しくなる
でもその分生きることは正しくなる
せっかくその魚食べたんだから
やっぱり自分もそれなりに生命のために生きてなくちゃいけないというぐらいでも感じるかもしれません
はい 一応そこら辺 その話ちょっと置いておきましょう
それからこの純粋にこのカルマの
カルマの分析 ちょっと時間はもうないんですけど
カルマの分析 ちょっと考えてみましょう
読み方はジャナカ ウパッタンバカ
ウパピーラカ ウパガータカ
日本語の単語もあります
説明してから日本語の単語を言います
で ジャナカというカルマのカテゴリーなんですね
ジャナカ 最後にカッマカッマと入れてもいいんです
ジャナカカッマ ウパッタンバカカッマとかね
こっちもカンマ入れた方がいいんです
長いんだから書かなくてもいいんです
ジャナカカンマっていうのは我々のを
の 何て言いますか 生まれる業なんですね
あるエネルギーが我々は産ませるというかね
生み出しちゃうんですね
あるエネルギーで我々は人間として生まれちゃうし
あるエネルギーで牛は牛として生まれちゃうし
だからあの生まれるカンマというか
そのあるカルマであるエネルギーで生まれたら
死ぬまでそのエネルギーで生きていられるんです
で どんどんエネルギーは消えちゃいます
消えて まあ最後に死んでしまっちゃうんです
これ日本語の単語あることあるんだけど
あの あまり意味が通らないかもしれません
順番ですね 順番に  業もう一回
そういう四種類のあの業があるんです
で どんな生命でもこちら書いておくの
これどうやって読むんですか？ 霊生ですかね
霊生ですね  霊じゃなくて命でしょ
一応 あ 霊ですね 霊ですね
まあ霊生 まああの強引に漢字入れてるだけなんです
まあなんとか漢字にしなくちゃいけないんだから
とにかく生命が死んでから生まれる
この生まれるエネルギーが
エネルギーがこの霊生というものなんですね
まあそれだけでいいと思います
この死事業 それで生まれてからのことで
生まれた命を支えてくれる業がまたあるんです
まああの どういうことかというと
あの 例えばまあ人がこの
まあ普通の人間に生まれていると
もう突然何か大変お金が誰かから入ってきましたと
それでいきなり人生がもっとさらに幸福になっちゃう
もう豊かになるでしょうし
そういうふうに支えてくれる業があるんですね
で そこはこの 例えばこういうこと
地獄に生命がいると その生命の命を支えてくるのは悪いカルマなんです
もっと長生きしなさいと
人間の場合は もう我々の命を支えてくれる何か業があるならば
それはいいカルマなんですね
人間長生きしなさいと
健康で長生きしなさいと言われたら
それはいいカルマであって
動物に長生きしなさいと言ったら
それは悪いカルマなんです
そのどんな生まれてくれたカルマを支えるカルマに支持業と呼ぶんです
次にあるのは言葉通りに妨害業なんですね
で 例えばこのすごい健康な体で生まれた人が突然事故に遭うとあって
足がなくなっちゃうと
それからその人は足がない障害で障害者として生きていなくちゃいけないし
一生生まれた時は完璧に生まれたんだけど
やっぱり途中で障害者になったりすると
その場合はもうもしかするとそれ業であるならば
それは妨害業なんです
殺害ですか 殺害業っていうのは
やっぱり途中でその生命を殺しちゃうと
死んじゃうと で 人間でいえば
例えばこのまあ 例えば子供一人殺されたりですね
人間で子供に生まれたんだから
やっぱりもうどうせ長生きするまで寿命はあったはずなんです
80歳  90歳になるまで生きていられるぐらいエネルギーを持っていたんです
別に障害を持って生まれたわけじゃないんだから
でも途中でその子を殺されちゃったんですね
その場合はまあ殺害業なんです
そこで私は死んで地獄に落ちだします
その地獄だったら 例えば 1億年間いなくちゃいけないんだと
この落ちたところの寿命は全部いなくちゃいけないんです
カルマはどうであろうか
私は虫虫 1匹殺しちゃったんだと
それで悩んじゃって 死んだところで地獄に落ちたならば
その地獄の寿命が 1億年だったら
1億年いなくちゃいけないんです
それで私は虫 1匹殺したところで悩んだところで
私もハエになって生まれたんだと
ハエになったら 1週間で死んじゃうんです
そういうふうに この生まれた次元の寿命はどうしても運ばなくちゃいけないんです
それで それは途中で切れるカルマは殺害業なんですね
前の例に戻りますけど
私は例えば地獄に落ちたと 1億年いなくちゃいけないんだけど
地獄に落ちた瞬間 私はほんのわずかなことではないかと
いっぱいいいことをしたんではないかと
何か他のことを思い出したりすると
すぐそこで過去でやったいいことを思い出したりして
早く死ぬかもしれません
だから地獄で早く死ぬことはいいカルマの結果で
人間で早く死ぬことは悪いカルマの結果になるんです
ですから このいいのかわかりませんけど
殺された子供がやっぱり悪い業の悪い業の結果で寿命が短くなってしまっちゃったんですね
その業の主体はどこにあるんですか？悪い業
主体と言ったっても 自分の心そのものなんですね
支持業っていうのは その生まれた瞬間を支えてくれる業というのは
その業の主体は自分の中にあるんですか
自分の心そのものなんです
殺害の場合はどうなんですか
殺害 殺害業の場合 で それも同じなんですね
あの 例えば人間にいるでしょう
なんか早くなんか暗いことを考えて
早く寿命を短くしちゃうとかね
で 余計なことをしてね
まあ自殺して 例えば麻薬を使ったり
悪いものをやったりして
寿命を短くしちゃう その人がどうしてもそれをやらずにいられない風になっちゃう
自分の気持ちなんですね
例えば殺された場合でも
やっぱりそういう環境に入っちゃったりして
もうなんとなくそういう風になってしまう
自分の自分が健康で長生きしたいと思うならば
例えば例えば 子供同士で怒って仲が悪くなっていても逃げるんです
逃げないでやっぱり当たってみようと思ったりするし
例えば車事故を起こしたりする人々いるでしょ
わざとスピード出しちゃう
なんで出すのか全然本人も別に
ただ出さずにはいられなくなっちゃうんですね
あのエネルギーは心から出て行けちゃうんですね
それで死んじゃったと
じゃあ 全部業が自分の心なんですね
心から出るんですから
で あの わかりやすく簡単な例で言うならば
例えば毎日包丁で野菜を切ったりしているでしょう
全然指が切れないでしょうに
たまに切れる時があるでしょうに
なんで切れた？その時何か自分がちょっとなんか気持ちがなんかちょっと揺れてるんじゃないですか
こうやったら切れる 指が切れるぞと知っているのにも気をつけなくてやっちゃって指が切れちゃうと
わずかなそういうことでも
やっぱり心から出てくるんです
それ毎日そういう風にあることなんですね
別にただそういう四つの分析がありますよということで
そう 例えばこの人が生まれた
生まれた時も神経が弱くて
体がすごい弱くて 白血病で生まれたというと
まあ長生きする可能性はないんですね
それでその人のこの令生業はそれぐらいなんですね
令生業自体が弱い だから生まれつきもういろいろ遺伝的に病気を持っていて
その人はまあ十五歳で死んだということは決して殺害業じゃないんです
その場合は どうしても十五歳までいたことさえも不思議だよと思われるかもしれません
すごい健康な体で生まれた赤ちゃんが
もう何も問題なく 体も心も
それで十五歳で殺され死んじゃうと
もう殺害業なんですね
私たちの場合はこの殺害業よりは
この支持業と妨害業は結構体験したことがあると思いますね
自分の人生はいろんなところで支持されたり
いろんなね 支持されたことがあったりして
またいろいろ邪魔されたことがあったりとか
そういうのはまあ結構味わうことは誰でもあるんです
殺害 殺害を味わったら
もうそれでその人がいないんだから
もう聞くことはできないんですけど
まあその四つだけ覚えておいてください
もう一つの四つに分け方があるんです
[背景のノイズ]こういう 4つの言葉なんですけど
ガルカン あ ガルカ アーサンナ
アーチンナ カタッタ 一応漢字があります
離れてますけど  こうかな
どんな意味ですかね この
わかんないです どういう意味ですかね
これ こう くっついてかもしれない
え？こう こうかもしれない
こうかこうか 離れてるか
わかんないんだけどね
これだって印刷？これ
これだって印刷かな いやあの
字がね ちょっとよく印刷がわかんない
離れたように見える 意味でわかるものですか
まああの そっか この 4つの
あの あまりこの漢字にとらわれないでください
この ただ何とか まあ漢字当てただけのことでね
あの 別にあの意味書くのは難しいんです
で これは生命が死んでからどこかに生まれるんですね
生まれる時はどんなカルマで生まれるかという説明なんです
前言ったのは 生まれてから死ぬまでどういう風になるかっていう 4種類
今はどんなカルマで生まれるかっていう 4種類
ガルカっていうのはもうそれは文字通りに重業なんですね
重いカルマ 人が重い罪を犯しちゃったら
必ず次に死んでからその重い罪によって生まれ変わる
もし人が重い善行 善 善行をしたならば
次に必ずそのカルマの結果得られる
いわゆる死んでからすぐ
この重業っていうのはどういうものかというと
悪い方で言うならば まあ親を殺すこと
殺生の中でも殺生した人は確実に次の生まれで地獄に落ちるってことはないんです
でも 母親か父親か殺しちゃったら
もうどうしようもないんです
その人は確実に次の生まれで地獄に行くんです
いわゆるものすごい不幸な次元に落ちるんです
ですから この殺す相手の徳によって
あの 殺すカルマの重さ
強さがあるんです ですから
尊い人を殺しちゃったらすごい罪
もうどうでもいい生命を奪っちゃったら
まあそれなりの罪と 殺生
たとえ殺生という言葉も同じかもしれませんだけど
殺されるものによってもカルマは変わるんです
だから魚殺すことと人殺すことは決して同じではないんです
仏教でこう言うんです
例えば 5人  10人 例えば村人 200人集めて
我々は祭りやりましょうと
ですから 豚一頭 まあ殺して焼き肉でもしようかなと
豚で焼き肉しますか分かりませんだけど
そうすると村の 200人も参加しているんですね
それで 200人も同じ罪を犯したかというと
そうじゃないんです その人その人の気持ちによって
またカルマが変わっちゃうんですね
例えばやっぱりやりましょうというリーダーシップを取る人の場合はすごいカルマが多い
そんなことやらなくてもいいんじゃないかと言って
思う 思う人のカルマが少ないし
本当は嫌で嫌で もう強引で参加させるんだから
まあどうしようもなく参加する人が
もう気持ちは向こう 他の方いるんだから
その人のカルマはまた少ない
ですから 同じ業を人したら種類の業なんです
ですから 殺生にしたっても
ものすごいもうわかりにくいほど複雑なんです
蚊を殺す 蝶々を殺すと
同じ殺生です 同じ虫だから
そうじゃないんです 罪が変わっちゃう
どっちが重い？どっちが少ないか
私に聞いたって私もわかりません
誰もわかりません その人の気持ち次第
それでこの 何て言いますか
今 スポーツとして釣りがやってるでしょうね
それも殺生ですけどね
スポーツとして海に行って魚を捕る人もいるし
職業として魚を捕る人々もいるし
同じ業じゃないんです
どんな差があるかとも
それはもう私はもう正直にさっぱりわからない
これはお釈迦様でないとわからないんです
人の気持ちと殺される側の状態によって変わるんです
で 生命匹だからね 例えば鯨匹殺すと
で 小さな小魚匹殺すというと
やっぱり鯨っていうのは巨大な生命なんです
簡単には殺せませんね
ですから その場合は罪が多いんです
すごい殺意なければ鯨を一頭殺せません
そういう風に動物の大きさによってもカルマが変わっちゃうんです
それは動物ではなくて
殺される側の徳によっても業が変わっちゃうんです
たとえ殺生の場合も そういう風にもうすっごい複雑なんです
人殺しにしたっても 大量殺人する人がいる
頭狂っちゃって この人はもうどこへ行っても人殺すんだから
誰かその人を捕まって殺したとする
それで仙人のような人がいる
国の人々みんなもう助けてくれ
その人を殺しちゃう それで罪が違うんです
ですから そこら辺は考えない方がいい
一番安全なのはしないこと
とにかく 他の安全な道がないんです
じゃあその中でも 生きている者にとって
特に人間にとっては 自分に対して
自分の命に対して 自分の母親父親ほど自分の命を支えてくれた人がいないんです
ですから 仏教ではそれは一番重い罪として扱っているんです
それから聖者を殺すこと
心清らかにしている聖者を殺すことも重い罪に入っちゃうんです
決して殺してはならないということ
同じくお釈迦様に害を与えることも
もうすごい重い罪に入っちゃうんです
それほど尊い人がいないし
お釈迦様は元気で健康でいたならば
数え切れない生命に役に立ちますからね
その方にちょっといじったりしちゃうと重業になっちゃうんです
またあるんです 仏教の世界で言ってるんだから
出家しているアマサンタ
形を犯したりすると それも重業になっちゃうんです
それはどういうことかというと
せっかく女性で出家して解脱をしているんですね
それで出家したんだから
誰も守ってくれる人がいないんです
森の中 一人でどこかに小さな部屋を作って
そこで一人で生活してるんです
犯したい気持ちがある人にとっては
もう何ももう問題ない
でも何かやったら もうその人にはもう重業
その人は瞑想しても悟れません
そのカルマからこの場合だけ抜けられないんです
重業を起こしたら 重業を起こさない限りは
修行して悟る可能性はいつでもあるんです
たとえ漁師でもう 年間魚を殺していたんだと言っても
後でそれは良くないとわかったところで
すぐ出家して修行しちゃったら
悟れる可能性は十分あります
悟ったらもう全部カルマを乗り越えて終わってるんです
大丈夫です でもこの重業を犯しちゃったらもうどうしようもない
次の生まれで確実にすごい恐ろしい地獄あるんです
この日本でも有名です
その地獄の名前は阿字比地獄ですか
アビジという名前なんですけど
そちらに落ちちゃうんですね
で そちらの寿命っていうのは
この太陽系が壊れてしまうまでいなくちゃいけないんです
なんかこちらの太陽系と関係なんかあるみたいんです
一光年 それぐらいいたら
まあ他のところへまた生まれ変わっちゃうんです
永久的じゃないです  2番目
まあ重業を起こす人っていうのはほとんどないでしょう
世の中に で 近業ですかね
読み方は 近業っていうのは死の間際というか
一番最近やったこと 死ぬ瞬間から計算すると
最近やったカルマが次の生まれが決めちゃうんです
それも普通の人は気をつけなくちゃいけないこと
例えば ずっと生まれた時からのいいことをしていたんだけど
最後になんか悪いことをやってしまっちゃったら
それ心に残っちゃうんですね
そうするとそれで次の生
生まれが決めちゃう だから
前ストーリーで言ったような場合も
あの人 年間人殺してきたんだけど
最後の瞬間ですごい堂々たる聖人になってお布施できて
もうなんか話も聞いたんですね
それで喜んで喜んでいて
すぐ心臓発作を起こして死んじゃったんです
だから天国に行ったんです
ですから 人が人で 生命誰でも死ぬ時は最近した業によって生まれ変われちゃう
3番目は最近やったことがなければ
このずっとやってきて
この癖に習ってきた行いによって決めちゃうんですね
ということは 例えば漁師さんの場合はプロだから
頭の中にある知識全部漁師の知識なんですね
どんな時期魚が来るんですか？どんな時船出ればいいんですか？とか
空気の見て 今はもう今日の感じだったら取れませんと
そういう知識しかないんですね
結局は ですから 何でもその角度で見たりするし
例えば政治家の方だったら何でも政治の角度で見るし
会社やってる人はなんだかんだもう商売の角度で物事を見ちゃうし
そういう風に我々もう慣れたこと
結局それにプロになってしまう
そういう慣れたことのカルマに
業によって生まれちゃう
4番目はもう慣れたことがない場合は
習慣としてやった善行為か悪行為もないんだと
その場合はなんらかの行為の結果で確実に生まれ変われる
いわゆるどっちかに生まれ変わるということ
ということは 人間というのはどうしても瞬間瞬間善行為か悪行為しているんだから
何かに引っかかって そこで次に生まれ変わる
生まれ変われないことはないんです
悟らない限りは で 現代の人々に理解できないかもしれませんだけど
例えば私はここで今死ぬ瞬間で
今世のことを何も思い出せなかった
出せなくなかったと それでも遠い遠い昔
過去生でやった業でもサッと思い出せるんです
その時 その時心の働きというのはすごいおかしいんです
この死ぬ瞬間で 体と全く関係なく行動するんです
それですよ このティベット仏教で
あの死者の書とかなんとかとか
もういろいろ書いてある
あれはほとんどこの あの仏教の基本的な真理とは違いますけど
あのいろいろおかしいところいっぱいありますけど
一応その時は頭はすごく自由に活動するんです
コントロールできない
そういう 4種類があります
もう時間になりましたけど
また